bene da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono faringei oggi
siamo su un gameplay molto particolare
perché si tratta della seconda parte del
video di google facial ter se non avete
visto la seconda sarà bellissima prima
parte nella lancio da sotto ringrazio
tra l'altro appunto google per
l'opportunità datami per parlare di
questa cosa anche perché comunque è un
gioco che tratta la sicurezza online nel
senso che vi ricorda anche di cambiare
insomma le vostre password mondo spesso
e l'isola di proteggere i vostri account
protegge ticos account ragazzi quindi
una cosa molto molto importante un bel
messaggio dietro la sentenza che prima
di cominciare dico io su questa cosa e
che come le password dovrebbero essere
un po come un po come le mutande cioè
cambiate le spesso non lasciateli in
giro e non prestate la nessuno perda la
perla di saggezza della giornata
iniziamo con appunto space scelto gioca
ora ho detto amo i colori di google
sull'ala dell'astronave vediamo cosa che
cosa capo a frey aver giocato un sacco
di giochi nello spazio dovessero scegli
l'astronauta
io andrei di tutta rossa sono i mains
questi ti chiamo il benvenuto a bordo
comandante mettiti alla guida della
sonore la sicurezza ti aspetta la tua
missione attraversare la galassia
proteggendo la tua strada ea 33 chiaro
in tutta sicurezza sulla base space
shelter dovrai evitare ostacoli previsti
e alieni stava bene con questo viaggio
potrai mettere alla prova le tue abilità
acquisirne di 9 va bene lavare i
progressi ma stavolta sta cavando meno
gravi se non stava bene team di
formazione gli assoluti di chiede
sostenere una prima prova prima di
metterti alla guida la zona del tutorial
classico perché ho anche alla nasa lo
faranno quando guida tutto pronto si
parte ma qual è la password più
utilizzata nell'unione attenzione quasi
alla pa i quiz che elio la password più
utilizzate dell'universo
ovviamente allora io che sono matematico
noi era una battuta non fa ridere e
ovviamente
per quattro ma il proprio classico
classico anche la mia di youtube non
scherzo non provateci non è quello cosa
possono fare gli astronauti per
migliorare la sicurezza del computer
dell'astronave eseguire un backup delle
foto mantenere le app a giornata
l'ultima versione non cambiare mai la
password allora non cadere mai la
password è sbagliato perché la password
bisogna cambiarla e subirà make up delle
foto dire mantenere le app a giornata
l'ultima versione giustamente le sembra
giusto quante password sono state rubate
dai pirati spaziali ultimi anni 44
milioni o 4 miliardi
ecco che vi si corona e
44 milioni o contro l'ia e non lo so
negli ultimi anni quanti anni intende
non lo so
a quanti astronauti non hanno cambiato
la prima passione tutti e cinque anni
sono io
davvero cambiata cambio rispetto il 30
per cento solo io ho settato recenti 70
100 ai cos'è il pitching per la lo so io
quando bevo un sacco un tentativo
fraudolento date le informazioni dati
sensibili messaggio di tipo commerciale
non richiesto credo che sia il tentativo
fraudolento lì o telefono sensibili
esatto
mamma mia è tutto prodotto qua tutto qua
classifica 2 fa due pali j per aver
prezzo di 12 canzoni fantastiche
atletica siena due fattori due file
nell'archivio teti alzando i fattori
bellissimo grazie aver risposto in tutto
giusto raga sono è un fenomeno fenomeno
stato fatto un genio grazie a tutti
basta viola minuto e l'astronave qui
imparerei a creare una passat efficace
per esplorare l'universo ora ai
l'obiettivo la visione che creare un
codice di accesso davvero sicuro per ora
tu per noi per il computer
dell'astronave tutto pronto iniziamo
bano al nas sono carico perché la paz
innanzitutto una parola di almeno otto
lettere una parola
volete che non sia correlata a me ok
scopo la tua password matematica
adesso vediamo la più complessa ecco la
parola passo con una lettera maiuscola
matematica con la lettera maiuscola ok
scrivi la tua la passano in modo
corretto lo aspetta tema chicca mamma
mia come sono bravo a scrivere con i
numeri non me la cavo ma a scrivere
esatto fino a qua ci arrivò lo zio per
rendere ancora più vicina essere un
numero per rafforzarla
l'altra passione matte sa tattica ok
ok
aspettare difficile uno dei simboli
dollaro pato passo ok
ma è come faccio a ricordarne la memoria
difficile è un codice di accesso davvero
sicuro bene ma ricordava ancora dopo un
minuto ricordare queste passo non è
sempre facile ma poi gli altri aiutati
utilizzando gestore le password che è
uno strumento che crea memorizza è se
riesce perché la password complesse
univoche team di formazioni astronauti
dice che per usare un gestore passo è
sicuro è un modo efficace per sala
sicuro ok gestore e password non solo io
non posso gestire fasolino e sonda
cassini settore sia un programma bene
cioè male di te non mi ricordo ancora
mia sia si aggiungono al tuo codice di
accesso sicuro fornendogli la sola mondo
più livello di protezione ma cio non sia
autentica azioni due fattori
autenticazione che ho fatto ovviamente
per creare diversi tipi di scudo vediamo
di capirne di più comunque ragazzi
notificazioni due fattori e lo scudo
definitiv
che cos'è la dedicazione a due fattori
via sms quando richiesta
l'autenticazione due fattori viene
inviato un codice altro telefono sms ti
possa essere questo vicine sabato
si parte valena una croce dove si ha il
mio numero
oddio
ok aspetta
895 13
io sarò da ragazzi la faccio tutti i
giorni perché effettivamente mi
accostano tutti sta roba
quindi per me e per me e io so
praticamente loggando nel mio account
sembra un processo stellare ma è mai
c'era il tempo notato c'era il tempo
cos'è l'autenticazione a due fattori
tramite notifica buona notifica
immediata al tuo telefono a quel punto
ti basta toccare il messaggio ricevuto
per dimostrare che l'utente sta provando
a scegliersi lavoro tu è vero quello un
altro è un altro tipo di accesso quindi
che è più facile perché non devi mettere
il numero dei suoi schiacciare notifiche
che arrivano
su questo
ma adesso starà tissimo col tempo guarda
un fenomeno fenomeno
record del mondo a
quanto fatto bene ragazza volta ce l'hai
l'autenticazione di due fattori
traditela authenticator cos'è la
patetica il tour genera codice di
verifica funziona per sé lo ha condotto
telefono e senza connessione telefonica
o dati inserisci questo codice quando ha
fatto l'accesso l'ex co questa è
un'altra qualcosa c'è mai addio ma voi
che macinava così complessa cos'è la
notificazione si è fatta di tante chiavi
di sicurezza una chiave di sicurezza è
qualcosa che colleghi al tuo dispositivo
quando effetti l'accesso per i mostrare
all'utente che stai provando a cedere
che sei davvero tu collega lo scudo
chiave in sicurezza al punto corretto
vamonos allora vi dico una cosa non è
mai così semplice per quando fitti la
chiavetta nel computer tu l'hai
inserirai matematicamente la chiavetta
in serie a è sempre tre volte una volta
dal lato giusto ma non c'entri il buco
quindi pensi che sia sbagliato poi
dall'alto che effettivamente sbagliato
quindi non entra e poi la reinserisce
quel quello giusto che era quello di
prima che però non centra tobini è
sempre così comunque ragazzi
congratulazioni lancio riuscito
all'improvviso però avvisti un cambio
i pirati spaziali stanno per tendergli
un agguato velo trucchetti allarme sta
inventando un campo di asteroidi
patio
madonna che schivato incredibili ho
capito dopo
il terminali fosse elettronica la storia
riceve un messaggio di cd se reale o
siccità telo in tentativo di agguato ai
mito miei dollari
per avere che saprebbe di pagare mi
segno sul 59 dai erano fra 9
io ho messo no della serie no non lo
faccio ora si è un tentativo fraudolento
ho sbagliato sorry
mi impegno stavolta provo un po di
schivate joe a livello pro mamma mia
ragazzi vedevo che faccio youtuber di
gaming
mamma mia fantastico e soprattutto in
modo sicuro il campo di asteroidi viaggi
spaziali hanno provato attenderti un
agguato senza riuscirci ora se ti stai
avvicinando alla fase spatial a questo
lo space elber il sì questa è la base
striscetta stato aspettando te spinale
al termine della toscana aver al
terminale dalto astronave sorry
e il momento di mostrare quello che ha
imparato sulla sicurezza spaziale si
superi questa tesi poi attraccare in
sicurezza bahamas
sono partiti o fatto zero errori non
credo sbaglierò qua spero qualche passo
non hanno cambiato la quante persone non
hanno capito da tutti ha passato cinque
anni saltava cento l'ho detto prima le
slot me lo ricordo cos'è il pitching ma
è solo quelli prima l'ho detto già
giuste metti in ordine questi sistemi di
sicurezza di casa o per il primo quale
quello che è sicuro ok chiave di
sicurezza ap authenticator sms messaggio
di ritiene non sbagliato beato vi
facciamo messaggio di allora e di
sicurezza il più sicuro a potenti gator
messaggio di richiesta l sms
credo
proprio lui mamma mia per la missione in
formazione di astronauti sicurezza e
l'astronave potenzialità gli scudi
pirati spaziali infatti permesso di
atterrare ok
entriamo nello stand shelter congratula
sono nativi sicurezza la space shelter e
colpito le tue conoscenze versamente io
trasmetti il tuo codice di accesso
supersicuro atene l'accesso alla
stazione di attracco della base tanto
bello anche il pezzo glielo passate
malascorta dispotico e missione compiuta
vado a noi ti è piaciuto sparge la voce
non c'è bisogno che lo condivida perché
lo sto facendo in un video quindi
ragazzine volete giocate appunto il
gioco di space shelter che appunto oltre
che essere molto informativo e anche
super divertente secondo me non fate
meglio di me quindi ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto mi raccomando mettete in
sicurezza le vostre password come sempre
come vi è stato spiegato anche lepido se
avete giocato appunto al gioco di space
center ringrazio google e per
l'opportunità di aver parlato appunto a
tutti voi della sicurezza online e
ricordatevi iscrivervi al canale con il
vostro account google ben protetto e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
se il ricordo dove ho messo il
telecomando ecco lo fa protetto da dieci
anni mercato un sacco di volte ma sempre
qua dai ragazzi
[Musica]
ma